à ceux qui s'interrogent sur son rôle
la finul apporte aujourd'hui un début de
réponse mais qu'est-ce que bleus
commencent à occuper l'espace évacué par
israël et qui leur étaient auparavant
interdit les libanais qui veulent
approcher la frontière comprennent vite
qu'il leur faut rebrousser chemin
ici nous sommes au sud de naqoura à 200
mètres de la frontière israélienne qui
est juste dans mon dos par leur présence
les casques bleus réduisent les risques
d'incidents en tout cas ici à cet
endroit car la frontière court sur 110
km et la finul n'en contrôlent pas la
totalité loin de là résultat cet après
midi au passage de fatima les soldats
israéliens ont dû tirer en l'air pour
éloigner des sympathisants hezbollah
qu'il est brocardée arrête dit le vieux
ou jeunes finalement quatre blindés de
la finul prennent position et
s'interpose mais l'urgence commande
aussi de vérifier le tracé frontalier ce
à quoi s'emploie les cartographes des
nations unies leur mission nous dit-on
durera plusieurs jours
l'objectif en fait final c'est d'aider
le gouvernement libanais à reprendre sa
souveraineté
et lorsque celui-ci la raf et achement
là je pense qu'il pourra prêter les
problèmes de désarmement
vaste ambition tenait justement au loin
une explosion sans doute le hezbollah
qui dynamitent une ancienne position
israélienne au sud liban il ya tellement
d'armes en circulation que l' escalade
menace à tout moment de leur quartier
général les casques bleus peuvent
observer la marine israélienne elle fait
des ronds dans l'eau prêtes à riposter
en cas de provocation néanmoins la
confiance prédomine
on attend de voir ce que ça va donner
mais pour l'instant les gens sont
heureux
la finul actuellement 4500 soldats
devraient doubler ses effectifs dans les
mois qui viennent parmi les nouveaux
sans doute des français dont les
compatriotes font leur possible pour
qu'il ne se sent pas dépaysé 22 ans
après sa création la finul et peut-être
maintenant en mesure d'assumer sa
mission initiale
il s'agit de veiller à l'application de
la résolution 425 des nations unies pour
laquelle beaucoup de casques bleus ont
déjà donné leur vie